July 2011 the worldview-2 satellite
captures an extraordinary image of a
lake that mysteriously disappears one
moment there's a lake and the next it's
gone what's going on the image shows a
lake called Loch ARIMA in County Antrim
Northern Ireland
it's like someone just check the plug I
that's extremely weird the lakes water
has to be going somewhere
Wilson analyzes aerial and ground
reconnaissance images for more clues I
went and looked at all the information
that I had available to us the maps from
the geology surveys have been done where
thought the water be coming back I'd
Wilson conducts an experiment to try to
follow the vanishing water I know that
this water is all coming from La Karina
because this is being traced using a dye
which was put in to flow Karima and the
dye was fine to come out at this
location above this point it's a
completely dry riverbed there's no water
in it at all
as you come round the corner of this
band then suddenly you have the spring
and the river starts flowing again how
the water gets to this point from la
Karima is still unclear the geology of
another vanishing Lake could offer a
clue Canada's Medicine Lake sits on an
unusual limestone landscape called karst
Medicine Lake in Alberta there's a great
example of a lake that each year drains
through the karst landscape beneath of
it essentially what happens are there
are sinkholes which form where the
limestone beneath the ground dissolves
over time to form a big cave
karst limestone could drain the water
from la Karima limestone is a very
porous rock maybe the water just seeps
away through that
[Music]
there is evidence of karst limestone
here but in this mysterious Celtic
landscape nothing is as it seems in
normal cars limestone you would
typically have large caverns under the
grind but here are actually lots of
different small channels and there's
lots of resistance in those so whenever
the pressure builds in the system then
the lick fills up but during dry periods
the lick has the chance to jariya night
and that's what the lick then then a
please Paula Wilson's investigation may
have uncovered where Locker Remus water
goes but the lake still holds secrets
one of the things that's confusing is
that the amount of water that's coming
out of this spring is twice the amount
that's actually going into a career why
this happens for now remains unexplained
there might be another vanishing leak
that we maybe haven't even seen before
it's still a big mystery
you